get in then meet its place christmas is
just around the corner so my buddy
Christian here is gonna hold up
mistletoe over my head
we're gonna see how many celebrities
will kiss me on the red carpet I think
it's gonna be steamy oh yeah who's the
best kisser of the group I'm definitely
the best you see would you say that
you're like a good kisser
um I think I like kissing I'll have no
complaints so that's a really good thing
either a lot of holiday traditions are
you gonna oh oh my oh my god Oh
what is that it's uh that marijuana is
bad news so Jeff what is that okay
please we don't do this in sweet I don't
know what that is either
I think you put it in your soup I don't
know what people do I'm Jewish but I
think people share that truth it is it
true that I'm Jewish yeah so what's
gonna happen yeah what yeah but but I
just wouldn't what do we do you want to
oh yeah we say this way what I kiss him
ever got like really really just really
to get in there just just get in there
doing a hug
okay we gotta do a video Thank You
Conrad perfect that's like basically
what you're supposed to do right
get in then get it both place that was
lovely
it's so good so no kisses today done
okay I think so is it something I did
uh yeah a little bit like top ten kits
for me probably top five top five Wow
what we have a sex play let's get in
here let's dance guys
guys again what an interview he's got
really guys the moment is nigh we are
finally at One Direction to kiss me
underneath the mistletoe do you think
we're gonna get them I tried you know 1d
was here I tried what's up
I tried oh I'm not gonna kiss you know I
wanted one direction